former deputy prime minister lord
hesseltein is
with us now hello to you my lord um
preferable to get a deal which is
reassuring
um how will last week's events impact
on the trade talks do you think i'm
thinking particularly about
dominic cummings and lee kane going and
also the prime minister not able to
have face-to-face talks if necessary
well i think they don't help but i
wouldn't over
exaggerate the significance of that
the facts are very clear we are
poised on a situation of either no deal
or probably quite a flimsy deal
covering parts of the economy and
there are no good news stories in this
uh
brexit is going to be a disaster for
this country
there's virtually no prospect of an easy
deal with the united states i myself
don't think there ever was but
it's even less likely now and the really
sort of depressing thing in all of this
whilst kobe looks as though there may be
a way out
with the vaccine and the testing the
really depressing thing
is that the government is doing nothing
to mobilize
the british industrial and commercial
economy
for the fight to adjust to whatever deal
happens
over brexit there's a
an opportunity there to mobilize
the economy led by the local elected
mayors
and that is being ignored there's
progress
under david cameron and george osborne
but that has all
now been reversed in significant measure
and the enthusiasm and energies that
need to be built up
to help readjust our economy are simply
not taking place
but if we if we don't manage to reach a
deal with our european friends by the
end
of the year we leave on world
trade terms which means tariffs on
traded goods as our viewers will know
this morning but
eu tariffs on most things are are pretty
low less than three percent
um cars and agriculture very different
but generally
so even if we did that it would give us
time then
to negotiate deals with other parts of
the world wouldn't it
well we've been trying to do that for
some time
and the outcome is minimal there's been
a deal with japan which
broadly preserves the status quo
as though we had remained within the
european union i can't think of any
other significant range of deals that
have taken place
but i think you missed the important
point
that whilst you may think that the price
increases of the tariffs are relatively
unimportant
what about the delays at the frontiers
what about the forms and the regulations
the uncertainty the breaking of supply
lines
all of these things are the sort of
hidden evil
of creating barriers between ourselves
and our most important export market
so it's not just the question about
tariffs
it's the whole apparatus of leaving the
arrangements we have carefully built up
over the last 40 years and i must say
that personally having watched this
whole
issue evolve from the second world war
when we celebrated the anniversary just
the other day
i couldn't help think that this was
incredible to me that britain who played
such an incredible role in those wars
was the country that broke the political
solution
which is the european union that was put
in place
to stop all that happening again i
cannot believe it is my
country that has done this
you you say there are other things as
well as tariffs you're quite right
police and security
operations being one of them the eu
saying if we are out of the club then we
won't be able to access them as
easily surely it's in the best interest
of all for us to keep close in that
regard
it would have been in the best interest
of us all not
to leave the european union in the first
place and
we we've mentioned terrorists we've
mentioned supply lines
what about the damage to the united
kingdom the
irish issues are not resolved and are
not resolved by wto terms
scotland is on the brink of voting to
leave the united kingdom and all of
these problems are there
looming one simple reason
it's our fault we did it and
there's no point mincing one's language
and pretending it's all going to be all
right in the morning it's not
and we need to be prepared and we are
not prepared
um nevertheless we are where we are um
democratically the people of the united
kingdom decided that they wanted to
leave the european union
um are you suggesting that it's still
not too late to change their minds
it's not too late it is too late now to
actually stop
and trade the process um
it's quite interesting you asked me the
question in in the context of the
resignation of two of the leaders
who once in power
indicated the sort of complete
unsuitability that they were for the
exercise of decision making as opposed
to the making of populist noises that
appealed
to sections of the community
who are you referring to
oh dominic cummings obviously and his
colleague
lee kane they have now left
do you think that the prime minister may
soften his view
certainly we saw a tweet from
our spokesperson uh leading the
negotiations
uh lord frost in uh in the european
union he's in brussels today as as you
know
and it tended some people are reading
into the tweet that potentially he may
still want to leave
without a deal if necessary but there
may be some softening
within government well
look you and i have one thing in common
along with very
virtually everybody else none of us
actually know
what is going on because all we get is
the spin
both sides are preparing either to show
that they
themselves achieved a great victory
which is not conceivable because the
other side is not going to suffer a
great defeat
there has therefore to be compromises or
they have to be
their briefing in order to make sure
that when it does collapse
someone else gets the blame so we're
being
manipulated politically in that sense
by the spin doctors i don't know what
the state of the real negotiations are
and there's no way i could know so all i
can do is to make judgments about the
substantive
conclusions that it might emerge deal or
no deal
both are bad a deal is
just a little less bad
um my lord i'm sure we have more than
one thing in common but sadly we're out
of time so we can't go into it now but
it's always good to see you thank you
for joining us on the programme this
morning thank you
thank you michelle